get ready for a whole new DC Universe or
mostly new at least DC Studios heads
James Gunn and Peter Safran have
unveiled their plans for a new chapter
and it's quite a change in Direction
even fans of DC's movie and TV output
would have to admit its offerings have
been a mixed bag over the past few years
for every great Triumph like the Batman
and Peacemaker there have been misfires
such as Black Adam and Wonder Woman
1984. beyond that the company shared
movie Universe which fans call the DC
extended Universe has become a
convoluted mass of retcons and
contradictions making keeping track of
it a chore thankfully it seems that DC
media is about to turn a new Leaf under
the leadership of James Gunn and Peter
saffron the recently named bosses of DC
Studios shortly after taking up their
new positions gun and saffron got to
work overhauling the dceu and it's one
of you know our jobs mine and Peters is
to come in and make sure the DCU is
connected on top of rebranding it
assembly the DC Universe they've made
more than a few changes that have
certainly ruffled some feathers Henry
Cavill is no longer Superman Wonder
Woman 3 isn't happening and Aquaman
actor Jason Momoa might take on the role
of Lobo to name a handful of these
alterations Gunn also has a revised DCU
release slate for fans to get excited
about and he has finally unveiled it to
the world
Jenna Bush of Slash film attended gun
and suffering's DC Universe announcement
event where he revealed dcu's first
chapter dubbed Gods and Monsters the
idea is not that different from a phase
in the MCU first the gun shed some light
on a project fans have known about for
some time his Superman film titled
Superman Legacy will introduce a new
continuity with a non-traditional
superhero movie saffron explained it's
not an origin story it focuses on
Superman balancing his Kryptonian
Heritage with his human upbringing gun
likewise shared that the DCU won't
always Focus strictly on good guy vs bad
guy conflicts the film aims to premiere
on July 11 2025 though no actors have
been revealed
foreign
unveiled Supergirl woman of tomorrow as
the title implies this film will be
heavily inspired by writer Tom King's
Comics run of the same name King is in
fact one of the driving creative forces
behind the DCU gum revealed that
compared to Superman who was sent to
Earth and raised by loving humans his
cousin Kara wasn't so lucky
I wouldn't devour you with the
destruction of Krypton she takes refuge
on one of the remaining fragments of the
planet where she watches everyone around
her slowly die off during her formative
years no release date yet has been
announced the woman of tomorrow
moving away from the children of Krypton
gonna announce some vastly different
Productions next up is Swamp Thing a
dark investigation of the Monstrous lead
character's Origins which saffron
promises will be a fine example of how
tonally varied all of their upcoming
movies will be then there's the
authority based on the team that finds
its roots in the wildstorm comics
imprint Gunn said that this is a passion
project of his that will be big that is
about a team of superheroes who are more
than willing to do atrocious things so
long as they're achieving their goal of
helping the world of course it wouldn't
be a DC film discussion without some
mention of the cash cow himself Batman
in addition to confirming the
continuation of director Matt Reeves
Batman franchise gun and Safran are
working on a separate movie called The
Brave and the Bold in quite a departure
from most batman-centric movies this
feature will Center on a version of The
Dark Knight as well as his son the
trained assassin Damien Wayne neither
Ben Affleck nor Robert Pattinson will
play this Batman expect some parallels
to writer Van Morrison's Batman comics
run and the appearance of other bat
family members in October 2022 it was
revealed that the longest state in Green
Lantern series was being reworked to
feature the iconic Jon Stewart as the
lead now gonna set the record straight
revealing that Stewart will be charging
up his ring alongside the greatest Green
Lantern of all Hal Jordan furthermore
the series in question may not be the
massive sci-fi Opus that fans expected
lanterns will focused on an earth-based
mystery that gets investigated by the
two aforementioned space cops evidently
the inspiration here Will Be True
Detective it's an interesting take that
will definitely be a far cry from the
Ryan Reynolds movie
have you concluded admiring yourself
uh yeah
in general the differences between
Jordan and Stuart's personalities
promises a lot of Juicy conflict with
Stuart more by the book and Jordan the
Loose Cannon warla will finally bring
the DC universe's most diabolical string
puller into a starring role and Delta
leave still a bit myth to have been
double crossed by her own stuff
following the events of the suicide
squad the new Standalone story in Waller
is set between the first and second
season of Peacemaker and already has an
impressive dynamic duo working on the
plot Scrib's Duties are being handled by
Crystal Henry who worked on HBO's
Watchmen along with Jeremy Carver who
created the recently canceled Doom
Patrol given that this is an Amanda
Waller story it's only fitting that all
other details are classified however we
can assume that we'll probably see her
on-screen daughter and peacemaker's best
buddy Leota adebayo somewhere in the mix
in a world of kryptonians Dark Knights
that ring slinging lawmen Booster Gold
is an absolute sham I was a failure in
the future just like I am
clearly why fans love him and this will
be the focus of his brand new show when
it arrives Booster Gold will see a
wannabe hero from the year 24
442. it has a hard time being taken
seriously so what does he do he nabs
some highly Advanced future technology
time travels to the 21st century and
makes himself out to be a big deal
superhero while talks with an unnamed
actor are confirmed no names have been
mentioned whoever it is it'll be great
to see booster clumsily rubbing
shoulders with the true heroes of the
world dropping buckets of sweat as he
worries about how long he'll be able to
keep the light going
the Creature Commandos first appeared in
1980s weird war tales as a World War II
Squad made up of a vampire a werewolf
and of course a Frankenstein's monster
guns animated take on the team will see
Rick flag senior the father of Joel
kinnaman's character from The Suicide
Squad leading a team of Motley monsters
comprised of amphibian woman Nina
mazurski Dr phosphorus Frankenstein's
monster the Bride of Frankenstein GI
robot and even The Suicide Squad Legend
weasel while we anticipate an animated
series more against the bone-stopping
violence action of invincible given the
characters involved it's fascinating to
see such a niche DC property entering
this new DC Universe at the ground level
gun has given the go-ahead to take us to
the homeland of Wonder Woman before she
became such a Wonder herself for a
series described as being full of drama
and Intrigue Paradise lust looks back to
the earliest years of the mascara and
lays out the essential details about how
this island came to be to be clear don't
expect this to be a younger Wonder Woman
show because one of the key details we
know is that it will take place before
Diana's birth it's not clear whether
other characters from the movies like
hippolitzer and antiope will appear
[Music]